GOOD MORNING.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
SENATORS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE'RE GONNA BE LEADING PRAYER IN
THIS THURSDAY BY OUR CHAPLAIN
SISTER MICHELLE WARMING.
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GONNA ASK ALL
MEMBERS TO PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE'RE GONNA BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
PAN.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE AGAIN.
MARIE CURIE SAID.
NOTHING IN LIFE IS TO BE FEARED.
IT IS ONLY TO BE UNDERSTOOD.
NOW IS THE TIME TO UNDERSTAND
MORE.
SO THAT WE MAY FEAR LESS.
GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL GODS.
LEAD US OUT OF THE FAMILIAR
SETTING OF OUR DOUBTS AND FEARS.
BEYOND OUR PRIDE AND OUR NEED TO
BE SECURE. TO THAT SPACE WHERE
WE CAN LINK OUR PASSIONS WITH
COURAGE.
OUR HOPES WITH DISCIPLINE.
AND OUR LOVE WITH PERSEVERANCE.
HELP US TO LISTEN.
SO THAT WE MAY UNDERSTAND THE
CRIES OF THE BROKEN HEARTED.
AND THE STRUGGLES OF THOSE IN
DANGER OF LOSING HOPE.
MAY THOSE WHO LOOK TO US FOR
LEADERSHIP.
EXPERIENCE THAT COURAGE AND
COMPETENCE THAT IS OUR CALL
AMEN.
BEEN SALUTING OUR NATION'S FLAG.
WELL PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO OUR OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL
.
WELL GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
AS CENTER WIENER MAKES HIS WAY
TO THE PROTEINS DESK WE WANNA
WISH YOU A VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
TO OUR VERY OWN.
SENATOR HER TADO WHO HAD A
BIRTHDAY THIS WEEK.
MEMBERS WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE.
TURN YOUR ATTENTION [inaudible]
LET'S.
WE'RE GONNA ASK ALL MEMBERS TO
PLEASE.
TAKE A SEAT.
AS WE HAVE SOME VERY SPECIAL
GUESTS IN THE CHAMBERS.
CENTER WIENER TO PROTEST DESK.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AS RESIDENTS --
COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU HIS EXCELLENCE
THE WONG DONG WHILE --
THE CONSUL GENERAL OF THE
PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF CHINA AND
SAN FRANCISCO --
THIS IS THE AMBASSADORS FIRST --
VISIT TO THE SENATE FLOOR SINCE
--
PREVIOUSLY --
HIS INTERNATIONAL POINT MEN'S
HAVE INCLUDED --
AMBASSADOR TO THE KINGDOM OF
TONGA IN CONSUL GENERAL IN ROOM
BY INDIA --
DESPITE SOME CURRENT TENSIONS
BETWEEN OUR OUR NATION --
AND OTHER PEOPLE PUBLIC OF CHINA
--
CHINA REMAINS AN IMPORTANT
FRIEND AND PARTNER AT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA --
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF NORMALIZED
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND CHINA
ESTABLISHED IN --
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE IT IS AN
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE TO WELCOME
THE CONSUL GENERAL TO THE SENATE
FLOOR TODAY --
PLEASE EXTEND A WARM SENATE
WELCOME.
WE HAVE AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO CANCEL GENERAL.
WELCOME TO THE STATE SENATE.
WE INVITE ANY AND ALL MEMBERS OF
THE STATE SENATE TO PLEASE JOIN
CENTER WIENER.
THE COUNCIL GENERAL THE BACK OF
THE CHAMBERS FOR AN OFFICIAL
PHOTOGRAPH
[inaudible]
SENATORS.
MARCH IS A POPULAR MONTH FOR
BIRTHDAYS IN THE CHAMBERS THAT'S
WISH A VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
IT'S HIS THIRTY FIFTH SENATOR
GORGEOUS
[inaudible]
SENATORS.
IF WE CAN HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
PRESENTATION.
AT THE PRO TENNIS DESK.
CENTER GALGIANI IS PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
I'M PREPARED TO ADVANCE
RESOLUTION.
GOING TO TAKE THE RESOLUTION
FIRST.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETEEN BY SENATOR
GALGIANI RELATIVE TO WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WEEK.
CENTER GALGIANI THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
S. C. R. NINETEEN TO CELEBRATE
THE WEEK OF MARCH THIRD THROUGH
NINTH AS WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION
WEEK.
AND TO HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANT
ROLES WOMEN PLAY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
ACCORDING TO THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION WOMEN WERE EMPLOYED IN
SECTORS OF THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE
MILLION WOMEN WHILE WOMEN ONLY
MAKE UP 10% OF THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IN THE UNITED STATES.
S. C. R. NINETEEN CELEBRATES
WOMEN AS VISIBLE AND VITAL
COMPONENTS OF THE INDUSTRY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT AS A MEMBER OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I WANTED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R. NINETEEN
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY COUPLE
YEARS AGO HERE IN SACRAMENTO. TO
ADDRESS A GROUP OF INTERNATIONAL
WOMEN IN THE BUILDING TRADES AND
WHEN I WALKED IN THE ROOM AND
SAW.
OVER A THOUSAND WOMEN
REPRESENTING ALL ASPECTS OF THE
BUILDING TRADES I HAD TO CHECK
MY OWN IMPLICIT BIAS.
ME JUST BE CLEAR YOU KNOW WHAT'S
UNIQUE ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY --
COLLEAGUES IS RECOGNIZED AS WE
STRUGGLE TO TALK ABOUT --
WORKING CLASS JOBS LIFT
THEMSELVES OUT OF POVERTY YOU
KNOW HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
WOMEN TO TRANSITION INTO
NONTRADITIONAL FEELS FEELS WHERE
THEY CAN BUILD A FULL CAREER
HAVE PENSIONS AND HAVE BEYOND A
LIVABLE WAGE SHOULD BE OUR
COLLECTIVE GOAL SO IT'S A
PLEASURE TO WELCOME ALL OF YOU.
TO THE SENATE FLOOR TODAY AND
AGAIN I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. C.
R..
NINETEEN THANK YOU CENTER
MITCHELL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
DEBATE AND DEBATE ON THE FLOOR
LAST CALL.
CENTER GALGIANI WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
IT'S TRULY AN HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
ALL THESE OUTSTANDING WOMEN
TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE MISTER SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DOURADO.
BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH
[inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK I'M REAL.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
HI MY COUNTY.
HI WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
HI IS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO TURN OUR ATTENTION
TO CENTER GALGIANI. TO INTRODUCE
SOME VERY IMPORTANT GAS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR GUEST AT
THE BACK OF THE FLOOR TODAY WITH
THIS WE HAVE KELLY COLIN.
DEANNA CAMPBELL LANE HIM WOMAN.
KIMBERLY COOK KATHY SKIN.
DEANNA BOWLER AND WE HAVE
SEVERAL MEMBERS WHO ARE ALSO
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING AND
THANKING THEM FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
TO SENATORS WE INVITE
[inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS. TO THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS. TO TAKE AN OFFICIAL
PHOTOGRAPH
[inaudible]
CONGRATULATIONS
SENATORS.
WE ARE A CHATTY BUNCH TODAY.
IF WE CAN PLEASE TURN OUR
ATTENTION.
TO SENATOR PORTANTINO.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
THANK YOU IS PRESENT PRESIDENT
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR MY
HONOR TO INTRODUCE FOURTH AND
FIFTH GRADERS FROM OUR LADY THE
ASSUMPTION SCHOOL FROM CLAREMONT
CALIFORNIA IN THE GREAT TWENTY
FIFTH SENATE DISTRICT.
PLEASE GIVE A WARM WELCOME TO
FOURTH AND FIFTH GRADERS.
THERE THEY ARE.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
SENATORS WE'RE GOING TO BE
ADVANCING.
WITH OUR SESSION TODAY.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
WE LIKE TO MOVE WITH MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR MARCH FOURTH
THROUGH THE SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE TAKING ON
OUR DAILY FILE.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
SECOND READING FILE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION.
NINETEEN THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY.
MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING.
WE'VE ALREADY DISPENSED WITH
ITEM NUMBER.
SIX ELIGIBLE FOR TODAY ARE
ITEMS.
FOR FIVE SEVEN AND EIGHT PLEASE
BE PREPARED TO TAKE UP YOUR
ITEM.
AS WE CALL YOUR NAME.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO START WITH
ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR SENATOR JACKSON'S PREPARED
TO PRESENT.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
JACKSON RELATIVE TO
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY THE
MORNING CENTER JACKSON THE FLOOR
IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT S. C. R. THIRTEEN WHICH
RECOGNIZES MARCH EIGHTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN AS INTERNATIONAL
WOMEN'S DAY.
I COULD GET THE ATTENTION OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THIS VERY
SIGNIFICANT EVENT.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
IN THE UNITED STATES THE FIRST
NATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY TOOK PLACE
IN NINETEEN OH NINE HUNDRED AND
TEN YEARS AGO.
IN HONOR OF THE NINETEEN OH WAIT
GARMENT WORKERS STRIKE FOR
BETTER WORKING CONDITIONS THE
TOOK PLACE IN NEW YORK.
THE FIRST INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S
DAY TOOK PLACE IN.
NINETEEN ELEVEN AS MORE THAN ONE
MILLION WOMEN AND MEN.
FROM A NUMBER OF COUNTRIES
PARTICIPATED IN RALLIES
DEMANDING RIGHTS FOR WOMEN.
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
WHAT A NOTION THE RIGHT TO HOLD
OFFICE?
THE RIGHT TO VOCATIONAL
TRAINING.
AND OF COURSE WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WOMEN ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO DO SO THEY
JOINED ALL THE PROFESSIONS
PROVIDING INCOME AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
WE ALSO --
THEY ALSO MARCH FOR THE RIGHT TO
WORK.
AS WELL AS CALLING ON AN END TO
DISCRIMINATION IN THE WORKPLACE.
SOME OF THE SOUNDS SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR TO TO TODAY.
BUT AT THAT TIME THESE WERE
QUITE ADVANCED NOTIONS.
SO IN CELEBRATION OF THIS GLOBAL
MOVEMENT FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS
EVERY YEAR THE UNITED NATIONS
HAS DESIGNATED THE THEME FOR
THIS IMPORTANT DAY.
AND THIS YEAR'S THEME IS
ENTITLED THINK EQUAL BUILD
SMART.
INNOVATE FOR CHANGE.
THE TEAM FOCUSES ON INNOVATIVE
WAYS TO ADVANCE GENDER EQUALITY
AND THE EMPOWERMENT OF WOMEN.
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREAS OF
ACCESS TO PUBLIC SERVICES.
AND SUSTAINABLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE AS I THINK WE ALL AGREE TO
ADDRESS GENDER PAY IN LEADERSHIP
GAPS.
ACCESS TO SOCIAL PROTECTIONS AND
ENSURING GENDER RESPONSE OF THE
ECONOMIC POLICIES FOR JOB
CREATION.
AND POVERTY REDUCTION TO HELP
WOMEN INTERNATIONALLY AND RIGHT
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES AS
WELL.
SO MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING US YOUR THIRTEEN IT
NOT ONLY SERVES TO COMMEMORATE
MARCH EIGHTH IS THE DAY OF
CELEBRATION FOR THE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS.
THAT HAS BEEN MADE FOR WOMEN'S
RIGHTS AS A RESULT OF SO MANY
EXTRAORDINARY WOMEN.
AND FEW GOOD MEN HELPING TO
ADVANCE THOSE IMPORTANT CAUSES.
BUT IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT STILL
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATE JACKSON DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR WE'RE GONNA
START WITH CENTER DRAWS SO.
IN CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
THIRTEEN WHICH HONORS THE
STRENGTH.
AND ENDURANCE OF WOMEN.
THE ECONOMIC STRENGTH OF OUR
SOCIETY DEPENDS ON WOMEN'S ROLE
IN THE LABOR FORCE.
WOMEN'S LABOR HAS ALWAYS BEEN
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR COUNTRY'S
WELL BEING BUT WOMEN HAVE ALSO
BEEN VULNERABLE. TO BEING
EXPLOITED AND UNDER VALUED IN
THE WORKPLACE.
CONSEQUENTLY WOMEN WERE AMONG
THE VERY FIRST LEADERS AND
ORGANIZE USE FOR RIGHTS IN THE
WORST WORKPLACE.
AS THE FIRST WOMAN LEADER OF THE
LOS ANGELES LABOR MOVEMENT I AM
HONORED THE CALIFORNIA'S LABOR
MOVEMENT REFLECTS THE STRENGTH
COMPASSION AND THE TENACITY OF
WOMEN.
WOMEN HAVE ORGANIZED FOR LABOR
RIGHTS FOR CENTURIES FROM THE
EARLY DAYS OF TEXTILE WORKERS
FIGHTING FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY.
TO ESTABLISH A WORK DAY A TEN
HOUR WORK DAY.
AFRICAN AMERICAN LAUNDRESS IS
WHO ONE YEAR AFTER THE END OF
THE CIVIL WAR FORMED A UNION AND
ORGANIZE A STRIKE FOR HIGHER
WAGES. TO LUCY PARSONS A MIXED
RACIAL WOMAN LEADING THE STAGE
THE CHARGE FOR THE EIGHT HOUR
DAY. NINETEEN THIRTY NINE A LOT
THE NOT ACTIVISTS NAMED LEE
SOMEWHAT ENDEL FOUNDED THE FIRST
NATIONAL EFFORT. TO CONVENE
LATINO WORKERS FROM DIFFERENT UP
FROM DIVERSE DIFFERENT ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS AND NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS LATER THE LOTUS WORK THAT
BECAME THE FIRST FEMALE LEADER
OF THE UNITED FARM WORKERS AND
DIRECTED.
THE DELANO GRAPE STRIKE NATIONAL
BOYCOTT.
AND WOMEN LEAD TODAY THE
JANITORS MOMENT THE HOTEL
WORKERS THE HOME CARE WORKERS
THE TEACHERS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
THANK YOU AND I URGE SUPPORT FOR
THIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO GOOD
MORNING SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
FOR BRINGING THIS.
TO OUR COLLEAGUE THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES FOR HER
REMINDER ABOUT THE RULE IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF WOMEN IN THE
ECONOMY IN IN OUR LABOR FORCE
AND I BRING. TO OUR ATTENTION
ALSO FRANCES PERKINS WHO WAS THE
VERY FIRST FEMALE SECRETARY OF
LABOR WHO BROUGHT US
[inaudible]
UNEMPLOYMENT [inaudible]
WORKERS COMP.
SOCIAL SECURITY.
AND SO MANY OTHER THINGS.
AND VERY FEW OF US EVEN KNOW
THAT IT WAS FRANCES PERKINS WHO
WAS APPOINTED BY FDR.
WHO WAS REALLY THE?
INNOVATOR OF THAT USUALLY WHEN I
STAND AROUND INTERNATIONAL
WOMEN'S DAY.
I TALKED ABOUT THE STATUS OF
WOMEN GLOBALLY.
AND I WILL REMIND US FOR A
MOMENT ABOUT THAT.
AT THIS VERY MOMENT.
WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING OVER AN
ANNUAL BASIS WERE TALKING IN
PRESENT TIME AT ALL TIMES ONE IN
THREE WOMEN GLOBALLY.
ARE IMPACTED BY PHYSICAL OR
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
THAT'S A CONSTANT.
THEY'RE ALSO SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION ADULTS GLOBALLY
WHO CANNOT READ OR WRITE. TWO
OUT OF THREE OF THOSE ARE WOMEN
[inaudible]
AND SIX HUNDRED AND THREE
MILLION WOMEN LIVE IN COUNTRIES
WHERE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS NOT
CONSIDERED A CRIME
NO THOSE ARE GLOBAL STATISTICS
BUT WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT WE STILL IN THIS COUNTRY.
HAVE FAR MORE TO DO [inaudible]
A WOMAN [inaudible]
WHO IS [inaudible]
HURT [inaudible]
WERE MURDERED.
IS FAR MORE LIKELY TO HAVE THAT
INJURY.
OR THAT HOMICIDE AS A RESULT OF
HER INTIMATE PARTNER AND THAT IS
TODAY IN THE U. S..
WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT WOMEN.
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
ARE MORE AND MORE AND MORE.
BEING DENIED ACCESS. TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
NOT ONLY DENIED BUT JUST NOT
HAVING IT AVAILABLE.
AND SO WHILE WE MUCH OFTEN DECRY
THAT GLOBALLY.
IT IS.
A INCREASING AND STARRING WANT
TO CALL IT A THREAT IT IS REAL
AND IT IS NOW IN IT IS RIGHT
HERE.
AND SO I KNOW ALL OF US ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY PERSON HAS HEALTH ACCESS
AND THAT INCLUDES WOMEN INTO
THEIR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE.
AND I THINK OF THE SENATOR AGAIN
FOR BRINGING THIS TO A SYNERGEN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER JACKSON
JACK TO CLOSE THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM LA AND ALSO FROM A BERKELEY
FOR THEIR COMMENTS THERE IS
INDEED MUCH WORK TO BE DONE.
THE NOTION THAT WE ARE
CELEBRATING A BEGINNING THAT
HAPPENED A HUNDRED AND TEN YEARS
AGO AND YET.
AROUND THE WORLD IN OUR NATION
AND EVEN IN OUR OWN STATE THE
FIGHT FOR EQUALITY CONTINUES.
BUT IS NOT YET ACHIEVED SO I
WOULD ASK MY MALE COLLEAGUES AS
WELL TO REMEMBER THEIR SPOUSES.
TO REMEMBER THEIR DAUGHTERS TO
AND TO REMEMBER OUR SOCIETY
WHICH WILL BE BETTER OFF NGUYEN
ALL PEOPLE ARE TREATED EQUALLY.
WHEN WOMEN HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE SAFE?
IN THE WORKPLACE WHEN I'LL BE
ABLE TO COMPETE EQUALLY IN THE
WORKPLACE WHEN WE WILL BE SAFE
IN OUR HOMES WHEN WE WILL BE
SAFE ON THE STREETS.
WHEN WE WILL ALL COME TOGETHER
AS ONE PEOPLE WITH THE GOAL OF
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL?
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES AYE BILL.
I BRIDGES [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
BY DORADO.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
HI NUMBER.
I LIKE HEALTHY.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS JONES.
I IS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO BE MOVING
ON TO ITEM FIVE CENTER PENA
PREPARED TO PRESENT HE IS MISTER
SECRETARY.
CAN YOU PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE CENTER PAN GOOD
MORNING THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TO
SENATORS ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AT SEA ARE SIXTEEN I WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE.
THIS DAY HONORS THE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND JAPANESE
AMERICANS WERE UNJUSTLY
INCARCERATED DURING WORLD WAR.
TWO ON FEBRUARY NINETEENTH
NINETEEN FORTY TWO PRESIDENT
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT SIGNED
EXECUTIVE ORDER NINETY SIXTY SIX
LEADING TO ONE OF OUR NATION'S
DARKEST MOMENTS.
ORDER TO BRING ONLY WHAT THEY
GET PACKING A FEW SUITCASES
JAPANESE AMERICANS LOST HOMES
BUSINESSES AND PERSONAL
POSSESSIONS.
GUARDED BEHIND BARBED WIRE THEY
WERE INCARCERATED TEN DIFFERENT
INTERNMENT CAMPS THROUGHOUT THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES WESTERN
STATES INCLUDING CALIFORNIA.
JAPANESE AMERICANS HAVE FOUGHT
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS TO CONTINUE TO
TELL THEIR STORIES SO WE CAN
PREVENT HISTORY FROM REPEATING
ITSELF.
AND AS WE REFLECT ON THIS
HISTORY WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE UNDER ATTACK
TODAY.
THERE UNFORTUNATELY HAVE BEEN A
SLEW OF PROPOSED FEDERAL
POLICIES TARGETING IMMIGRANTS
REFUGEES AND UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION.
IS OUR DUTY TO REMEMBER HISTORY
IN CALL OUT AND JUSTICE AND TAKE
COLLECTIVE ACTION.
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO LIVE
IN FEAR THAT THEIR RIGHTS COULD
BE TAKEN AWAY AT ANY MOMENT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING US
YOUR SIXTEEN IS REMEMBER THE
IDEALS OF OUR CONSTITUTION AND
AS WE CONTINUE TO PUSH TOWARD A
BETTER CALIFORNIA A BETTER
AMERICA.
THANK YOU AND CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR PAN DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FOR LAST CALL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO YOU UTILIZING OUR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN.
NINE ICE THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE NOW ADVANCING.
TO FILE ITEM SEVEN PASS ON FILE.
SENATOR HILL FILE ITEM MAY BE
PREPARED.
PASS ON FILE.
MEMBERS THAT'S GONNA DO IT FOR
OUR SENATE THIRD READING FILE
FOR THE DAY WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE MOVING FORWARD WITH THEIR
SPECIAL CONSENT COUNTER.
WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ASK ANY
SENATOR IF THEY'RE WANTING TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THIS TIME.
HEARING YOU SEE NO SENATORS
STAND UP WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
EXCUSE ME PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETEEN ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWELVE AND A SOME
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
TWENTY THREE MISTER SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL.
BY FOR JUST [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK BY MORALE
[inaudible]
BY NELSON.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG.
BOB I COUNTY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
HI.
HI IS [inaudible]
THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO EXISTING COUNTER IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE HOLD FOR THIRTY SECONDS
[inaudible]
SENATORS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE WITH MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES THINNER
JACKSON FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU
RISE THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
RECONSIDERATION BE GRANTED ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SO THAT WE
CAN RETAKE THE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED
MEMBERS WITH ACTIVE.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL NOW.
ON FILE ITEM FOR WHICH IS S. C.
R. THIRTEEN IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO DO UTILIZING OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING YOU SEEN NO OBJECTION
EYES THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED SENATORS
WE HAVE A BUSY MORNING WITH
SEVERAL BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE IN SESSION
HERE TODAY.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT ON THEIR SUB
COMMITTEES.
SENATOR Y. CASKEY.
A SUBCOMMITTEE --
TO WITH THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW ON RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION IN A
CHAIN TRANSPORTATION WILL MEET
IN FIFTEEN MINUTES IN ROOM.
ONE ONE TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR AYE CASKEY CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL
MEET FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENTS [inaudible]
IN ROOM.
POLICIES DON'T REMEMBER MY ROOM
NUMBER --
POLICIES.
LET'S SEE.
IN ROOM ONE THIRTEEN THANK YOU.
ROOM ONE THIRTEEN PUBLIC SAFETY
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER SKINNER
CENTER RAZA.
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND
TEN MINUTES THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER DRAWS A SENATOR ROTH.
FAMOUS PRESIDENT --
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION WILL BE MEETING AT
TEN AM IN ROOM THIRTY ONE ANYONE
THANK YOU CENTER OUT HAVE A GOOD
WEEKEND ANY ADDITIONAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS FROM OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS.
IF THERE'S NO WHETHER BUSINESS
CENTER WILK THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE AND WE WILL RECONVENE
HERE ON ON MONDAY AT TWO PM
MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WILL BE
HAPPY BIRTHDAY AGAIN TO CENTER
BARGES WE HOPE ALL OF YOU HAVE A
VERY PRODUCTIVE WEEK IN THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM.
AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE MAY WE'RE GONNA
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM THANK
YOU MEMBERS